Earlier this year, basically, sort of the great lock-in of Christmas, we came back from the kernel competition on NVF4, which was one of our most popular competition yet that we worked on with NVIDIA. And the fourth place winner was like, oh, hey, like, I've never written a kernel day in my life, but I have the fourth fastest colonel in the world for gems, and I'm like, what? And then, like, a few days later, someone's like, oh, like, I'm a high school teacher. I don't even know what a kernel is, but, like, I have the fifth fastest kernel for, like, a dual gem problem.
今年早些时候，基本上是在圣诞节那段“大封锁”期间，我们从 NVF4 的内核竞赛回来，这是我们与 NVIDIA 合作举办的最受欢迎的竞赛之一。第四名的获胜者说：“嘿，我这辈子从来没写过内核，但我却拥有了世界上第四快的 GEM 内核。”我当时就想，什么？然后过了几天，有人说：“嘿，我是一名高中老师，我甚至不知道什么是内核，但我却拥有了第五快的双 GEM 问题内核。”
I'm like, thanks, Mark. And I'm like, okay, like, this is bizarre to me because it, and generally it felt like systems was this very gatekeeping thing. People are like, no, you're incorrect. People are like very grumpy. You know, sort of traditional vibe of the C++ programmer. Sorry for the sort of casual insult. But, but, you know, it was like not the most, like, friendly bunch because like there's sort of
我说：“谢谢你，Mark。”我心想，好吧，这对我来说太离奇了，因为总的来说，系统领域一直给人一种非常排外的感觉。人们会说：“不，你错了。”人们表现得非常暴躁。你知道，这是一种 C++ 程序员的传统氛围。抱歉，我这算是随口冒犯了。但是，你知道，它并不是最友好的群体，因为……
a lot of rigor in a lot of ways you can shoot yourself on the foot. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 303 recorded on July 20th, 2006. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue part two of our three-part chat with Mark Serafim. In this episode, we talk about open versus closed models, core auto-gpU mode, auto research, and more. I have two controversial questions for you, Mark. Question number one, what do you think about, you mentioned sort of the first, like, open models with a good license. What do you think about the state of open models versus closed models today?
在很多方面，严谨性很高，你很容易搬起石头砸自己的脚。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2006 年 7 月 20 日录制的第 303 期节目。我是 Connor。今天，我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 继续我们与 Mark Serafim 三部分访谈的第二部分。在这一集中，我们讨论了开放与封闭模型、核心自动 GPU 模式、自动研究等内容。Mark，我有两个有争议的问题要问你。第一个问题，你提到了第一批拥有良好许可证的开放模型，你如何看待当今开放模型与封闭模型的现状？
Yeah, it's a good question. Let me see. Like, it is just remarkable, like, how quickly some of the best, like, Chinese models have gotten. Like, basically, it sort of there was, I think initially this hypothesis that what they're doing is at best distilling. And then you're like, okay, maybe not. Like, maybe they're actually pretty good. I think there's sort of, like, a lot of open questions, like, where are the flops coming from? Where is the data coming from?
是的，这是一个好问题。让我看看。这确实非常了不起，一些最好的中国模型进步得如此之快。基本上，最初有一种假设认为他们所做的充其量只是蒸馏。然后你会发现，好吧，也许不是这样。也许它们实际上相当不错。我认为还有很多悬而未决的问题，比如这些浮点运算（FLOPS）来自哪里？数据来自哪里？
I think those questions don't tend to get very clearly answered in the technical reports. But at least, like, as far as, like, on architecture, research innovation, I think I'm seeing sort of fairly world-class work. I will say I've never myself worked at a like a frontier lab like Open AI or Entropic. So I don't know like what they have and how much better it is. But like based on the evils, like it can't be like that much better. And so I don't know. I will say though that like one thing that's I found like a bit disappointing though is that like you know like you might say well like you should just use an open model.
我认为这些问题在技术报告中往往得不到非常明确的回答。但至少在架构研究创新方面，我认为我看到了相当世界一流的工作。我得说，我自己从未在像 OpenAI 或 Anthropic 这样的前沿实验室工作过，所以我不知道他们拥有什么，也不知道他们到底领先多少。但根据评估结果来看，应该不会领先太多。所以我不知道。不过我要说的是，有一件事让我感到有点失望，那就是你可能会说，你应该只使用开放模型。
but the definition of local alum has changed a lot in recent times where like it's basically, hey, you have a GB 200 note for your local alum. Like, yeah, okay, bro. Like, it's a $6 million machine for a year, you know? Like, what are you talking about? Like, who's actually going to rent this out? Like, maybe. But to me that this always seems like it's going to be a niche thing.
但“本地大模型”的定义在最近发生了很大变化，基本上变成了：“嘿，你有一个 GB200 节点来运行你的本地大模型。”好吧，兄弟，那是一台一年价值 600 万美元的机器，你知道吗？你在说什么？谁真的会去租用这个？也许吧。但在我看来，这似乎总是一个小众的东西。
I do think there's something quite remarkable about like being able to sort of share like basically all requests in a batch with your friends basically or your company and then getting economies of scale out of that. But as far as I can tell, like managed inference providers would rather give you a managed deployment because it's just cheaper for them to do so as opposed to make you pay for usage, which is kind of like closer to what modal does. And generally, I think the pay for usage model to me is more economically aligned with your customers because you'll just get users and then you'll figure out like, how do I route them
我确实认为，能够与你的朋友或公司共享一个批次中的所有请求，并从中获得规模经济效益，这是一件非常了不起的事情。但据我所知，托管推理提供商更愿意为你提供托管部署，因为这对他们来说更便宜，而不是让你按使用量付费，这更接近 Modal 的模式。总的来说，我认为按使用量付费的模式在经济上与你的客户更一致，因为你只需要获得用户，然后你就会弄清楚如何路由他们。
tall to the same model, to the same priority, to the same batch. And if you're doing managed deployments, you're probably not going to do that. and there's going to be inherent waste and high margins because of it. But I think a lot of this is like, I think downstream of GPUs being scarce. So like if GPUs were not scarce, we wouldn't need these business models. I think paying for usage would be fine. So yeah, like in some sense, I think people, my sense is they overly focus on the like the weights question. But I also think there's like this whole ecosystem around it that like needs to like work out.
将他们路由到同一个模型、同一个优先级、同一个批次。如果你进行托管部署，你可能不会这样做，这会导致固有的浪费和高利润。但我认为这很大程度上是因为 GPU 稀缺。所以，如果 GPU 不稀缺，我们就不需要这些商业模式了。我认为按使用量付费会很好。所以，在某种意义上，我认为人们过于关注权重问题了。但我同时也认为，围绕它还有整个生态系统需要去完善。
I heard an interesting theory based partially on first hand experience. And the theory was that one of the reasons why there's a perception of a quality gap between the closed models and the open models is because the closed models have one inference provider and they can ensure the quality of that inference setup. Whereas for the open models, it can be served in many different ways. And there can be, and I did not realize the degree to which this can have, like who's serving your. inference for your model can have an impact on the performance, especially around things like tool calls, et cetera. And I didn't realize that. And I've actually heard that some labs have changed their licensing a little bit, not to make them more closed, but to prevent them from being served in a way that would create this perception of, oh, this model is so bad because I tried it on this
我听过一个有趣的理论，部分基于第一手经验。该理论认为，封闭模型和开放模型之间存在质量差距的感知，原因之一是封闭模型只有一个推理提供商，他们可以确保推理设置的质量。而对于开放模型，它可以通过多种方式提供服务。我以前没意识到，谁来为你的模型提供推理服务会对性能产生多大影响，特别是在工具调用等方面。我没意识到这一点。我甚至听说一些实验室稍微修改了他们的许可协议，不是为了让它们更封闭，而是为了防止它们以某种方式被提供服务，从而造成“这个模型太烂了，因为我在这个提供商那里试过”的负面印象。
one provider that did not have a proper setup. I mean, it's a good question. I mean, like, I, like, as I sort of think through this, I think there's like a bit of an like iceberg here, which is like if you're like, you know, one way you could be an inference provider is like, you just have GPUs and then you just like, you know, via LMSG lying and then you charge people for tokens. You know, like slightly, you know, deeper would be you're like, okay, I'll call a compiler and I'll like make sure kudographs are applied, you know, slightly deeper is, you know, maybe you write a few custom kernels here and there, you know, a bit deeper as you provide the fine-tuning service for your customers and then let them redeploy those.
那个提供商的设置不当。这是一个好问题。当我思考这个问题时，我觉得这里有点像冰山一角，比如作为推理提供商，一种方式是你拥有 GPU，然后通过 vLLM 运行，并按 Token 向人们收费。稍微深入一点，你会调用编译器，确保应用了 CUDA 图。再深入一点，你可能会在这里或那里编写一些自定义内核。更深入一点，你为客户提供微调服务，并让他们重新部署这些模型。
And so you have to write some backwards kernels for them, which typically the Chinese labs do not provide. And then sort of the, but what I sort of like, and then what's interesting, even at this sort of, and then you have quantization, I think it's just very controversial because like people maybe don't mind being quantized,
所以你必须为他们编写一些反向传播内核，而中国实验室通常不提供这些。有趣的是，即使在这一层面上，量化也存在争议，因为人们可能不介意被量化，
but they'd like to know when they're being quantized, which is very bad because if you have some sort of like, let's say, priority queue thing going on. Like, okay, so let's do not manage the points. Let's say you're just like a normal user and you just hit a request to an inference. an endpoint. You may not even know if you're running on NVIDIA or AMD GPU, for instance. And then the numerics
但他们想知道自己何时被量化，这非常糟糕，因为如果你有某种优先级队列机制的话。好吧，我们不谈托管部署。假设你只是一个普通用户，向推理端点发送请求。你甚至可能不知道你是在 NVIDIA 还是 AMD GPU 上运行。然后数值
might diverge slightly. And so it's not like you're being nerfed. It's just like the numerics diverged slightly. And maybe they were only like thoroughly tested on NVIDia. And then you get like an AMD in France and you're like upset basically. Another one is like, you know, like AMD has a bit more VRAM. And so now like the batch size might be like a bit bigger if you're serving multiple requests. And the kernels might not be batch invariant. And so now again, you're numeric change and you're like, oh, why am I getting nerfed?
可能会略有偏差。这并不是说你被削弱了，只是数值略有不同。也许它们只在 NVIDIA 上经过了彻底测试。然后你得到了一个 AMD 推理结果，你就会感到沮丧。另一个原因是，AMD 有更多的显存，所以如果你同时处理多个请求，批处理大小可能会更大。而内核可能不是批处理不变的，所以你的数值又变了，你会想：“哦，为什么我被削弱了？”
And then finally, you could actually be getting quantized. Like, this is also like very problematic that like it's not sort of crystal clear. And I think why there's sort of sometimes on Twitter like some conspiracy theories around where people sort of say like, oh, like at 1am, Claude is quantizing us? Like, who knows? Like it could be like, is it running on Traynium? Is it running on like an H-100? Is it running on a GB300?
最后，你实际上可能正在被量化。这也是非常成问题的，因为这并不完全透明。我认为这就是为什么 Twitter 上有时会出现一些阴谋论，人们会说：“哦，凌晨 1 点，Claude 在对我们进行量化吗？”谁知道呢？它是在 Trainium 上运行吗？是在 H100 上运行吗？是在 GB200 上运行吗？
Like, is it like running, you know, on a CPU? Is it running with CPU offloading because it's running on an older generation A-100 that happens to be the data center. And so some of the layers are offloaded and computed on CPU. So there's sort of like a lot of unknowns, but I think a lot of it in my mind is like numerics suck. And as a vendor tries to make these straight off the safe cost, they might be creating numerics problems. And as a result, results won't be perfectly reproducible. And people might believe that they're getting nerfed.
它是在 CPU 上运行吗？是因为它在数据中心里碰巧是一台老一代的 A100，所以使用了 CPU 卸载，导致某些层被卸载并在 CPU 上计算吗？所以有很多未知数，但在我看来，很大程度上是因为数值计算很糟糕。当供应商试图在成本上进行权衡时，他们可能会制造数值问题。结果就是，结果无法完全复现，人们可能会认为自己被削弱了。
But yeah, I mean, it's fascinating to me that. And one of the things that I think interesting here is the non-deterministic nature of LMs means that it's very hard to tell whether something changes. And it's fascinating to me how, you know, like, we call it like Opus 4.8, but like the Opus 4.8 that you got at one point in time might be different from what you get at a different point in time. And, you know, like in any other part of the software industry, like a version would have like a concrete meaning. And if you just suddenly change the version that you were serving to your customers, like that wouldn't be cool. But in this industry, it happens all the time. Yeah. And I like, I've noticed, like, all sorts, just even switching, like, same model between, like, different, like, endpoints and providers within Nvidia's, like, the hub, like, sometimes it's like a weird behavior and, like, could this be, could this be, like, how I'm getting routed to this model?
但确实，这对我来说很迷人。我认为有趣的一点是，大模型的非确定性意味着很难判断某件事是否发生了变化。令我着迷的是，我们称之为 Opus 4.8，但你在某个时间点得到的 Opus 4.8 可能与你在另一个时间点得到的不同。在软件行业的任何其他领域，版本号都有具体的含义。如果你突然改变了提供给客户的版本，那是不合适的。但在该行业，这种情况时有发生。是的，我注意到，即使是在 NVIDIA 的 Hub 中，在不同的端点和提供商之间切换同一个模型，有时也会出现奇怪的行为，这会不会是因为我被路由到该模型的方式导致的？
And, yeah, I didn't realize before I got more into this, like, the degree of complexity that goes into serving inference for a particular model and how it can impact the quality that you get out of it. Yeah, I mean, what I will say, though, like, I am sort of seeing some light at the end of the tunnel these days because... So we recently had, like, James Demil, like, the linear algebra legend from, like, LaPoc, come give us a talk. And, like, one of the things you mentioned, like, I was, like, asking my question in private, like, about, like, formal verification. Like, can't we just, like, have better guarantees of, like, ways of testing these kernels? Because just as a baseline for your viewers, the way a lot of kernels get tested today is basically using, like, absolute and relative tolerances, which basically means, like, let's be a lot of kernels. which basically means, like, let's say your output is a tensor, you iterate over all the elements of a tensor,
是的，在我深入研究之前，我没有意识到为特定模型提供推理服务所涉及的复杂程度，以及它如何影响你从中获得的质量。是的，不过我要说的是，我最近确实看到了一线希望，因为我们最近邀请了来自 LaPack 的线性代数传奇人物 James Demmel 来给我们做演讲。我私下问了他关于形式化验证的问题。难道我们不能对这些内核有更好的测试保证吗？因为作为基准，今天很多内核的测试方式基本上是使用绝对和相对容差，这意味着，假设你的输出是一个张量，你遍历张量的所有元素，
and then you sort of compare them to, like, reference to, like, let's say, your faster implementation, and then you're like, are they far apart from each other? And typically, if, like, I don't know, they're within 1 to the e minus 3 of each other, people go like, eh, it looks fine. But, like, what do you mean it looks fine? Like, basically 1 to e minus 3 is, like, very big.
然后将它们与参考实现（比如你更快的实现）进行比较，然后看它们是否相差很远。通常，如果它们在 1e-3 以内，人们就会说：“嗯，看起来不错。”但你说的“看起来不错”是什么意思？基本上 1e-3 是非常大的误差。
And if it's, like, for Float 64, like, that's a more major issue than if it's for int 4. And so, like, what ends up happening is that, like, these values only ever increased. like if you look at by Twitch, for example, or most open source repos, A tolls and R tolls only ever increase because you usually get flakes to avoid the flakes, people just increase the tolerances. And we just don't have like a good way of knowing how to fix these problems because
如果是 Float64，这比 int4 的问题要严重得多。最终的结果是，这些数值只会不断增加。如果你看 PyTorch 或大多数开源仓库，绝对容差（Atol）和相对容差（Rtol）只会增加，因为你通常会遇到不稳定的测试，为了避免不稳定，人们只会增加容差。我们没有好的方法来解决这些问题，因为
we go like, oh, like, is it a Kuda driver thing? Is it like a library thing? Is it like a new bug in the kernel? And then like maybe the bug is okay because the performance speed up is okay, but maybe some customers are not okay with an 8% speed up if it changes the numerics slightly and maybe some are. Then, you know, there's like a long list of Pytroch issues that get open. end up of like, well, we're trying to, like, I have this CPU program that doesn't match my GPU
我们不知道是 CUDA 驱动的问题，还是库的问题，还是内核中的新 Bug。也许 Bug 没关系，因为性能提升了，但也许有些客户不能接受 8% 的速度提升，如果它稍微改变了数值的话，而有些人则可以接受。然后，有一长串 PyTorch 问题被打开，比如“我这个 CPU 程序和 GPU 程序不匹配”。
program. And then they're like, how come it's a bug? And you're like, well, it's not a bug because it turns out like, it's not like, Nvidia follows the entire I triple E format for like tensor cores. And like, that's just like something like we have to like understand and be okay with. But I think it's very counterintuitive like when you, when you first come across it. So just to bring it back to what James was saying, like what James's point was that like you cannot have element wise comparisons.
然后他们问为什么这是个 Bug。你会说，这不是 Bug，因为 NVIDIA 并不完全遵循张量核心的 IEEE 格式，这是我们必须理解并接受的。但当你第一次遇到它时，它非常反直觉。回到 James 所说的，James 的观点是，不能进行逐元素比较。
It's much superior to have like property-based testing. So for instance, we're doing a QR kernel. Like we just look at how orthogonal is Q and how triangles are. This is a much better way of doing like testing. And I think Lopac, it's like, again, it's like a shoulder of giant sort of thing. They've been thinking about correctness for decades. Whereas in deep learning, maybe we've been thinking about it for like nine years and we're not very good at it. And so this is like to me one area where we kind of need to look at what our predecessors did and then like understand like, you know, in some sense we know how far apart.
进行基于属性的测试要优越得多。例如，如果我们正在做一个 QR 内核，我们只需观察 Q 的正交性以及三角形的性质。这是进行测试的一种更好的方法。我认为 LaPack 再次体现了“站在巨人的肩膀上”。他们几十年来一直在思考正确性问题，而深度学习领域我们可能只思考了九年，而且做得并不好。所以对我来说，这是一个我们需要看看前人做了什么，然后理解在某种意义上我们知道浮点数相差多远的地方。
the floats are from each other. And so there's no, like, there's no secret there. And so, like, we should be able to just more rigorously think of how to set tolerances and what kinds of properties we expect our programs to have. And I just don't think we're there yet. Yeah, it's interesting. When I used to work on these astrophysics codes simulating, like, binary white dwarfs that'd be rotating around each other. And one of the ways that we checked for correctness was because this code was a code where it was rotating, it was very important to conserve angular momentum. So we would just, like, one of the checks was you sum up with very high precision the angular momentum across the whole grid. And, like, if you lose any angular momentum,
所以这里没有秘密。因此，我们应该能够更严谨地思考如何设置容差，以及我们期望程序具有什么样的属性。我认为我们还没有达到那个水平。是的，这很有趣。当我过去从事天体物理代码工作，模拟围绕彼此旋转的双白矮星时，我们检查正确性的方法之一是，因为这个代码涉及旋转，保持角动量非常重要。所以我们其中一个检查方法就是以极高的精度对整个网格的角动量求和。如果丢失了任何角动量，
then, like, your simulation isn't respecting the most important, like, law of physics that you're trying to simulate here, which is, like, conservation. And that was just, like, a simple, like, just from the physics, like, tests, the property of the system that you wanted to enforce. And, like, you know, yeah, like, we looked at, like, residuals and, like, other errors and tolerances. But, like, that was like the key thing. Like as long as we're not, as long as we don't have outflows of this one property. And the interesting thing too was when you were designing that simulation, there's a bunch of different quantities that were evolving throughout the simulation, like radiation and energy. And it was very challenging, like you have to kind of pick in shoes,
那么你的模拟就没有遵守你试图模拟的最重要的物理定律，即守恒定律。这只是一个简单的测试，基于物理，测试你想要强制执行的系统属性。是的，我们确实查看了残差和其他误差及容差，但那是关键所在。只要我们没有该属性的流出。有趣的是，当你设计那个模拟时，有许多不同的量在模拟过程中演变，比如辐射和能量。这非常有挑战性，你必须做出选择，
like which of these are we going to preserve quality for? And like we knew that this one, this was the variable that like was most important that like, if we didn't conserve angular momentum, then the whole simulation would become numerically unstable. But there were other things where it was like, eh, you know, if a little bit of this leaks off the grid, it's okay.
我们要保留哪些属性的质量？我们知道这是最重要的变量，如果我们不保持角动量，整个模拟就会在数值上变得不稳定。但还有其他一些东西，比如“嗯，如果一点点这个东西从网格中泄漏出去，没关系”。
Yeah. I mean, I like to compare this to how I remember us doing in Pi Torch in the Torche AHO project, how we do correctness testing for diffusion model quantization. And it would literally be, okay, well, you know, before the model gave a cat,
是的。我喜欢把它与我记忆中我们在 PyTorch 的 TorchAO 项目中对扩散模型量化进行正确性测试的方式进行比较。它字面上就是：好吧，你知道，模型之前给出一只猫，
okay, we quantized, okay, still a cat. You know, like, this was sort of like, so this was the way correctness testing was done. And then you're like, well, is it like, it's a bit, yeah, it's a bit question mark. But like, I think that was sort of the state of the, maybe it's better now.
好吧，我们量化了，好吧，还是一只猫。你知道，这就是正确性测试的方式。然后你会想，嗯，这有点……是的，有点打问号。但我认为这可能是当时的状态，也许现在好多了。
I don't want my diffusion friends to flame me. But like, but at least a year ago, this is what it was like. So there was another tough question I was going to have for you. But I'll ask a different question. So, okay, you said you've never worked at a Frontier Lab, but you're now working at Core Auto, which I don't know a lot about,
我不想让我的扩散模型朋友们攻击我。但至少一年前就是这样。我还有一个棘手的问题要问你。但我会问一个不同的问题。好吧，你说你从未在前沿实验室工作过，但你现在在 Core Auto 工作，我对它了解不多，
but I felt like there, from what I do know, your mission is like so appealing, so appealing to me right now as I am in search of automating all the things. So like, are you not working, you say you haven't worked yet at a frontier lab, but do you hope that the lab that you're at will eventually become a frontier lab? Like, what's the, is the mandate of Core Auto to, like, develop core technology that other labs would use? Or, like, is your goal, like, we're going to build a frontier model? Yeah, I mean, I think these things evolve quite a bit. But, yeah, I mean, like,
但我感觉从我所知道的来看，你们的使命非常吸引我，因为我正致力于自动化所有事情。所以，你虽然说还没在前沿实验室工作过，但你希望你所在的实验室最终能成为前沿实验室吗？Core Auto 的使命是开发其他实验室会使用的核心技术吗？还是你们的目标是构建一个前沿模型？是的，我认为这些事情会不断演变。但是，
I think the lab's like mission is to build the world's most automated lab and then figure out how to automate the rest of the world. And I think like basically there's a few good proxies for this, which is like of course like, you know, how quickly can we speed run towards like building like a frontier model? I think it's just like a really key component. And because we're making a lot of bets on architecture research, it was based on like when you look at like the talent we have on the team,
我认为实验室的使命是构建世界上最自动化的实验室，然后弄清楚如何自动化世界的其余部分。我认为基本上有几个很好的指标，比如我们能多快地加速构建一个前沿模型？我认为这是一个非常关键的组成部分。因为我们在架构研究上投入了很多赌注，基于我们团队拥有的天才人才，
it's just really critical that this set of researchers feels productive with the kinds of work they can run. And this is kind of where I come in, which is like on kernel alum generation. And so this I think is like a very key and underrated like pre-pre-rec, basically. I think of a lot of like auto research work, which is this like, hey, if you want to iterate on whether a research idea is good, but it's like four times slower than what it should be.
让这些研究人员对他们能运行的工作感到高效是至关重要的。这就是我发挥作用的地方，即内核大模型生成。我认为这是一个非常关键且被低估的先决条件。我思考了很多自动研究工作，即：如果你想迭代一个研究想法是否可行，但它比应有的速度慢了四倍，
Like that's bad. You know, one notable example that, you know, we worked on, Rice was like, you know, the QR kernel. Like the context there is that like, actually, maybe maybe I should take step back. Let's like a step back. So the step back is when I first started working on GPU mode, my impression was that like the bottleneck for progress was like an educational bottleneck. Like basically people just don't know how GPUs work. And if we thought people how GPUs worked, and then we gave them sort of good problems along the way and then made them more and more ambitious
那很糟糕。我们合作过的一个显著例子是 QR 内核。背景是……也许我应该退后一步。退后一步就是，当我刚开始从事 GPU 模式工作时，我的印象是进步的瓶颈是教育瓶颈。基本上人们只是不知道 GPU 是如何工作的。如果我们教人们 GPU 是如何工作的，然后给他们一些好的问题，并随着时间的推移让他们变得越来越有野心，
over time that people would figure out like how to use GPUs. And the interesting thing is that like basically near the end of our like and halfway through like GPU mode's journey, basically about a year ago. AI systems weren't very good at writing kernels. Like, they actually, they sucked. And the code they would generate would be incorrect. It would be slow. It would be sort of this hallucination between like Pytor,
人们就会弄清楚如何使用 GPU。有趣的是，在 GPU 模式旅程的末尾和中途，大约一年前，AI 系统在编写内核方面并不擅长。它们实际上很烂。它们生成的代码是不正确的。它很慢。它就像是 PyTorch、CUDA 和 Triton 之间的幻觉，并不连贯。然后今年早些时候，基本上是圣诞节那段“大封锁”期间，我们从 NVFP4 的内核竞赛回来，这是我们与 NVIDIA 合作举办的最受欢迎的竞赛之一。第四名的获胜者，
and Kudha and Triton. It was just like wasn't like super coherent. And then like earlier this year, basically sort of the great, you know, the great lock-in of Christmas. We came back from this kernel competition on NVFP4, which was like one of our most popular competition yet that we worked on with NVIDIA. And like the fourth place winner,
说：“嘿，我这辈子从来没写过内核，但我却拥有了世界上第四快的 GEM 内核。”我当时就想，什么？然后过了几天，有人说：“嘿，我是一名高中老师，我甚至不知道什么是内核，但我却拥有了第五快的双 GEM 问题内核。”我说：“谢谢你，Mark。”我心想，好吧，这对我来说太离奇了，因为总的来说，系统领域一直给人一种非常排外的感觉。人们会说：“不，你错了。”人们表现得非常暴躁。你知道，这是一种 C++ 程序员的传统氛围。抱歉，我这算是随口冒犯了。
was like, oh, hey, like, I've never written a kernel day in my life, but I have the fourth fastest colonel in the world for gems, and I'm like, what? And then, like, a few days later, someone's like, oh, like, I'm a high school teacher. I don't even know what a colonel is, but, like, I have the fifth fastest kernel for, like, a dual gem problem. Like, thanks, Mark. And I'm like, okay, like, this is bizarre to me because it, and generally, it felt like systems was this very gatekeeping thing. People are like, no, you're incorrect. People are, like, very grumpy. You know, sort of traditional vibe of the C++ programmer. sorry for the sort of casual insult.
但它并不是最友好的群体，因为在很多方面，严谨性很高，你很容易搬起石头砸自己的脚。所以社区变得更加难以进入和封闭是很合理的。所以我们现在处于一个世界，AI 在教人们 GPU 如何工作方面比我作为 GPU 模式的教育者两年里做得更好。
But it was not the most friendly bunch because there's sort of a lot of rigor in a lot of ways you can shoot yourself on the foot. And so it makes sense that the community would be sort of more inaccessible and gaited like a lot of things. So here we are. We're now in a world where like turns out like AIs are better at teaching how GPUs work than I was as an educator over two years in GPU mode.
是的。所以对我来说，我想，好吧，我们现在该做什么？所以看着它，我想，好吧，似乎人们只是不确定哪些问题值得加速。所以现在，作为一名教育者，我的职责变成了告诉人们哪些是需要加速的重要问题。线性代数内核的出现是因为我们在优化器研究中需要它们，特别是 Shampoo 优化器，我们的一位研究人员对此非常热衷。所以当我看到这一点时，我想，好吧，只要我们能非常清晰地制定问题，并拥有大量的奖励黑客设施，
Yeah. And so like to me it was like, okay, well, like what do we do now? Right. And so looking at it, I'm like, okay, well, it seems that people just maybe aren't sure which problems are worth accelerating. And so this is kind of like now, like, my duty, I feel as an educator has become like telling people what are important problems to accelerate. And so the linear algebra kernels came about because we needed those for our research on like optimizers, specifically like a shampoo optimizer that like Ron, one of our one of our researchers like very passionate about. And so when I look at this, I'm like, okay, well, as long as we can sort of like very clearly formulate the problem and have like a, lot of facilities for reward hacking.
我们就能在系统方面取得相当一致的突破。一旦我们做到了这一点，我的研究伙伴们就可以想出各种疯狂的想法。他们不需要招募我，而传统上他们需要这样做，我需要查看他们的代码，理解数学，编写内核。现在，我可以给他们提供反奖励黑客工具，然后他们就可以自己去做了。他们非常高效，永远不需要和我交谈。
Like, we can make fairly consistent breakthroughs and systems. And once we do that, now, like, my research buddies can sort of, like, come up with all sorts of, like, cursed ideas. And instead of having to, like, recruit me, which traditionally they would need to do, like, I would need to go look at their code, understand the math, like, write the kernel. Now, like, I can just basically give them tools for anti-reward hacking, and then they can just, like, go cook. And then they're very productive and they never need to talk to me.
这太棒了，因为我可以思考更通用的问题。我对这个领域非常热衷，原因有几个。我认为它不仅适用于内核，还适用于推理引擎、系统代码。你知道，像 PyTorch 这样的仓库未来会是什么样子？应用太多了。你可以使用自动研究来优化性能。如果你有相同的设置、相同的护栏、相同的奖励黑客预防措施，你也可以用它来简化代码，比如在不降低性能的情况下最小化差异。你可以用它来增加代码覆盖率。
And this is great because then I can think of, like, more general problems. And I'm very passionate about the space for a few reasons. Like, I think it applies to like not just kernels, but like, you know, inference engine, systems code. You know, what will repos like Pytrochs look like in the future? There's so many applications. Like, you know, you can use auto research to optimize for performance. You can also use, like, if you have the same setup, the same guardrails, the same reward hack prevention, you can use it to simplify code, you know, like minimize the diff without regressing performance. You can use it to increase code coverage.
任何可以测量和量化的指标，你都可以自动化。你所需要的只是到位护栏和正确性检查。是的，我认为当我与人们谈论自动研究时，他们认为我只是在谈论性能优化。他们没有意识到，
Like, anything that's a metric that you can, like, measure and quantify, you can then, like, automate. And all you need is, like, to have the guardrails and the correctness checks in place. And, yeah, I think, like, when I talk to people about auto research, I think they think I'm solely talking about just, like, performance optimization. They're not realizing just, like, how many,
任何可以成为迭代可测量过程的东西，你都可以自动化。然后你可以构建这些过程，将这些不同的循环链接在一起，构建这些工作流。是的，这感觉非常强大。我的意思是，至少我的观察是，我发现竞争排行榜的格式是一种非常强大的框架。因为首先，按照我的理解，
anything that can be an iterative measurable process, you can automate. And then, like, you can build, you know, these processes, you can chain these different loops together and build these workflows. and yeah, it feels so incredibly powerful. I mean, yeah, I mean, at least like my observation here has been like, I just find the competitive leaderboard format to be a very powerful framing. Because like, so first off, like, you are, like, the way I think of it, like, very broadly
你设置了一个评估，而评估仍然很昂贵，因为评估最终需要在真实的 GPU 上运行。所以这是一个真实的成本。但相对于人们为了在这些事情上做得很好而支付的 Token 成本，它实际上可以忽略不计。所以，我不知道你是否愿意分享。你最近的 Token 支出是多少？好吧，我想自年初以来我已经花费了 3000 亿个 Token。
speaking is that like you set an eval, and the eval is still expensive because the eval ultimately needs to run on real GPUs. So it's like a real cost. But it's actually negligible relative to the token costs that people end up paying to, like, do really well in these things. And so, actually, yeah, I don't know if you're comfortable sharing. You're the most recent token expenses. Well, I've spent 300 billion tokens, I think, since the start of the year.
核算成本的方法有很多种。但我刚开始接触这个时，我也担心在 GPU 上运行、租用 GPU 的成本。我肯定不再担心在 GPU 上运行的成本了，因为相对于 Token 成本，它微不足道。但如果让我猜，我会说，今天对于大多数问题，如果你想写一个光速内核，至少需要数千美元的推理成本。如果你只需要一个不错的，也许你可以少花点钱。但我开始看到变化的一点是，这个周末一件有趣的事情是，我开始看到人们从开放模型中获得更便宜的结果。
And there's various ways of accounting for the cost. But the thing that I, when I first got into this, I, too, was worried about the cost of running on the GPUs, of renting the GPUs. And I definitely, it is the case that I no longer worry about the cost of running in the GPUs, because relative to the token cost, it is, it is trivial. But if I had to guess, I would say that I think today for most problems, if you want to write like a speed of light kernel, it's, you know, in the thousands of dollars of inference at least, I think to do it to really. Like, if you just want like a decent one, you know, maybe you can get away with less. But the thing that's the thing that I'm starting to see changing and one thing that was an interesting thing from this weekend is I'm starting to see people getting results from the open models that are much cheaper.
比如我们在 EuroPython 冲刺活动中，在 Cholesky 问题上得分最高的人，他实际上是参赛者之一。当时有两个人，我和另一个人，我认为他最有经验。另一个人，我认为他对 CUDA 内核的经验没那么多，但他正在使用各种模型，包括一些开放模型。我还没检查他获胜使用的是哪种模型。但我知道我已经开始看到能够用开放模型获得有意义的结果，这也许可以大大降低成本。我认为问题之一是，如果你需要大量的推理才能在这些竞赛中取得好成绩，
Like one of the, the person from our group at the Europe Python sprint who has the best score on the Chillesky problem, it was actually one of the competitors. There were two, me and one other person who I think had the most experience. The other fellow, I think, didn't have as much experience with Kuda kernels, but he was using a variety of models, including some open models. And I haven't checked which of, which of the models he's been using is the winner. but I know I've started to see, been able to get meaningful results with open models, which could maybe lower the cost of this a lot. I think one of the problems is, you know, like, how do we, how do we, if you need to have a ridiculous amount of inference to do well in these competitions,
我们如何将其分发给研究人员和人们，以便他们能够学习，从而建立起这种技能组合？在当前的成本下，这似乎很难。是的，我比你更乐观。我是这样想的。假设你试图在一个节点上服务一个 MOE。基本上，如果你进行非常小的批处理推理，那么只有少数专家被激活。所以推理最终会相当快。
how do we, like, cede this out to researchers and people so that they can learn so that we can build up this skill set, it seems tough with the current costs. Yeah, I mean, I'm a bit more optimistic than you are. here's how I would think through this. Like basically, like, let's say you're trying to serve like an MOE on a node. Basically, if you're doing like very small batch size inference, then like only like a few of your experts are activated. And so the inference ends up being like quite fast.
但如果你是中等批处理大小，那么可能大多数专家都会被激活。所以，但如果你有很多用户和很多请求，那么这样做可能和中等请求规模一样高效，因为无论如何，你所有的专家都被激活了。所以这就像那些事情之一，这些东西确实受益于规模经济。但不是那种“我有一个 10,000 个 GPU 的集群，并且我智能地将事物路由到它们”的规模经济，因为那根本不是我认为很大一部分推理提供商正在做的事情。我认为他们做的是更多的托管部署。我认为这在定价和融资上更简单。你只需支付他们 B200 价格的一定利润，然后你就能获得 Token。所以，当我看到这一点时，对我来说，这是一种筛选，只要重点是在一个节点上，并且如果只有几个技巧很重要，比如 CUDA 图、几个内核、量化，
But if you're like medium batch size, then like probably most of your experts will be activated. And so, but then if you have a lot of like users and a lot like a lot of requests, it might be as efficient to do that than to do the medium request scale because anyway, all your experts are activated. And so it's like one of those things. where like it seems that like these things do benefit from like economies of scale. But economies of scale not in terms of like I have like a 10,000 GPU cluster and I'm
如果就是这样，没有更多的秘密武器，那么为什么不每个小团队或小组配备一个节点呢？对我来说，这在经济上似乎是可行的。如果模型达到 3 万亿参数，而这就是我们正在运行的东西，那么也许不行。因为，你知道，我喜欢向人们提到的一件事是，分布式计算在家用领域从未流行起来。你知道，我们有非常强大的笔记本电脑和手机，但我们很少有人家里有通信的集群。
intelligently routing things to them because that's just like not what I think a good chunk of inference providers are actually doing. Like I think they're doing much more managed deployments. I think it's like simpler to price and finance. Like you just pay them some margin on the price of a B200 and then you get like tokens back. So again like when I when I look at this to me, it's sort of a screen. like, well, as long as emphasis on one node and if there's like a few tricks that matter, like basically, goodographs, a few kernels, you know, quantization.
所以对我来说，这似乎永远是一个小众的东西。但是，是的，我更乐观。我认为有一个很好的良性循环，如果任务是让推理引擎更快，你可以想象拥有一些非常快且定制的东西。我认为作为 GPU 模式工作组，有一件事会很酷。所以如果有人有兴趣合作，我可能会和他们一起工作。关于什么的具体工作组？
Like if that's it and there's no more secret sauce, then like why not just have like a node per small pod or team? Like to me, that seems like pretty economically feasible. If the models get to three trillion and stuff and this is what we're running, like maybe not, then you're basically because, you know, one thing I like to mention to people is like, distributed computing never became popular at home. You know, like, we have very powerful, like, laptops and phones, but we don't have, like, it's very rare for people to have a cluster at home that communicates.
基本上，拥有一个非常便宜的推理服务的入门套件，你可以将其部署在公司中，并使用自动研究来分析请求。所以，类似这样的东西，我认为会非常有趣。我的梦想，我的梦想实际上是一个世界，当你获得下一个 NVIDIA 系统并安装 CUDA 时，有一个小工具，它只是：“嘿，把你现有的 CUDA 代码给我，我会把它移植到这个 GPU 上并让它变快。”我不会在广播中说出数字，但我可以给你们看。这是我的支出。
So that, to me, feels like it'll always be, like, a niche thing. But, yeah, I mean, I'm more optimistic. And I think, like, there's this nice virtuous loop where, like, if the task is make the inference engine faster, you could presumably imagine having something really fast and custom-made. It's, like, one thing I think would be pretty cool as a GPU-mod working group. So if anyone's interested in tech-teaming on that, I'll probably work with them on it. A working group on what specifically?
我以为它会增加一点，但没有，它在六位数。至少可以这么说。所以这是金额。直接来自 Claude 的 Anthropic 订阅是 500 亿个 Token。直接来自 OpenAI 订阅是 630 亿个 Token。来自我们内部推理中心的是 1620 亿个 Token。所以，也许还没到 3000 亿。但我不知道这是否完全准确。
Basically, having a very, like, basically, like a starter kit for a very cheap inference service that you can deploy at a company with, like, auto research that profiles the request. So, like, something like that, I think would be quite interesting. My dream is, my dream actually is a world in which when you get your next Nvidia system, like, and you install, like, you know, Kuda, there's like a little tool there that's just, hey, like, give me your existing kuda code and I'll just like port it to this GPU and make it fast. So I won't say the numbers on air, but I can show you guys. Here's my spend.
让我们看看，那是 1130 亿。好吧，接近 3000 亿。那是自年初以来的。但我也认为另一件事是 Token 成本随着时间的推移大幅下降，正如我所了解的那样，这是因为过程中存在浪费。
I thought it was going to go up a bit, but it's not, it's in the six figures. Can say that at least. So this is the amount. And then direct from Claude is direct from the anthropic subscription is 50 billion tokens. And then direct from the open-AIA subscription is 63 billion tokens. And then from our internal inference hub is 162 billion tokens. So that's like, maybe it's not 300 billion yet. But I don't know that this is entirely.
我开始看到 Token 效率的提高。是的。我不知道。Connor，你现在是多少？Connor 曾经在内部 Codex 排行榜上排名第七。我不知道。他们不再向我们展示排行榜了。
And let's see, that's like 113. And okay, it's close to 300 billion. That's through the start of the year. But also, I think one of the other things is that the token cost has gone down dramatically over time, and that's just been, as I've learned, the things that are wasteful that are being done during the process.
我也不怎么追踪。我的意思是，我也做了很多自动研究的事情。你应该告诉 Mark 关于……我认为大多数人现在已经停止谈论模型的局限性了，但你会听到：“哦，它不擅长 X。它不擅长 Y。”事实是，不，它现在擅长一切。只是你还没有设置正确的，你知道，
And I've started to see, like, increases in token efficiency. Yeah. I don't know. Connor, what are you at? Connor at one point was number seven on the internal, like, a codex leaderboard. I don't know. They don't show us the leaderboards anymore.
而且我开始看到，比如，Token效率的提升。是啊。我不知道。康纳，你现在到什么程度了？康纳有一次在内部的，比如，代码排行榜上排第七。我不知道。他们不再给我们看排行榜了。
and I don't really track. I mean, I do a lot of auto research stuff too. You should tell Mark about the... I think most people now have, like, stopped talking about the limitations of models, but like you hear like, oh, it's not good for X. It's not good for Y. And it's like, no, like, it's good for everything now. It just, you haven't set up the correct, you know,
我其实没怎么追踪。我的意思是，我也做了很多自动研究方面的工作。你应该告诉马克关于……我觉得现在大多数人已经不再谈论模型的局限性了，但你还是会听到，哦，它不擅长做X。它不擅长做Y。而事实是，不，它现在什么都擅长。只是，你还没有设置好正确的，你知道，
I don't know if you want to call it harness or agentic loops. system. Yeah. Mark left. I assume he's listening. He's got a separate. Well, you know, it's interesting. So I think most people have ceded that for these sorts of tasks, for a lot of tasks that, you know, yes, AI can do it.
我不知道你是想称之为“约束”还是“代理循环”。系统。是的。马克离开了。我假设他在听。他有一个单独的。嗯，你知道，这很有趣。所以我认为大多数人已经承认，对于这类任务，对于很多任务，你知道，是的，人工智能是可以做到的。
The thing that I still hear is like, yeah, but design or style or like somebody gave me an example of like, well, you know, a model, an agent wrote a new function instead of using an existing function. Like it should have tried to leverage some existing function and like lift it. And it's like, and like, how do we prevent that without human review? And, and I was talking with some other people about it. And somebody was like, well, you know, you could like, it's not easy to build like a machine checkable way to check for style for that. But for that particular case, you know, we probably could. You could build a tool that looks at like, that like parses the AST of the language and then compares the similarity of different like entities in the code. And if your diff introduces a new thing that's very similar to some other thing, then you could
我仍然听到的事情是，是的，但是设计或风格，或者有人给了我一个例子，比如，嗯，你知道，一个模型，一个代理写了一个新函数，而不是使用现有的函数。它本应该尝试利用一些现有的函数并将其提取出来。就像，我们如何在没有人工审查的情况下防止这种情况？而且，我正在和其他人谈论这件事。有人说，嗯，你知道，你可以，比如，构建一种机器可检查的方法来检查风格并不容易。但对于那个特定的案例，你知道，我们可能可以。你可以构建一个工具，查看，比如，解析语言的抽象语法树（AST），然后比较代码中不同实体的相似性。如果你的差异引入了一个与其它事物非常相似的新事物，那么你就可以
build a deterministic tool that says like, hey, you should have used this other tool. Like maybe we just haven't been trying hard enough to turn all of the like design sense and code style things into machine checkable rules. Maybe we can. This is kind of what makes working at a like a different to your lab. interesting is that like indeed I think as a user of these models like probably your best bet is coming up with like linters on top like basically and those linters could be other AI systems or they could just be like actual code but like to me when I hear the problem of like well the ais used to many trix up blocks or they like reinvent the wheel a lot of those are RL problems
构建一个确定性工具，说，嘿，你应该使用这个其他工具。也许我们只是没有足够努力地将所有的设计感和代码风格转化为机器可检查的规则。也许我们可以。这正是让在不同的实验室工作变得有趣的原因，因为确实，我认为作为这些模型的使用者，你最好的选择可能是想出一些类似代码检查工具的东西，基本上，这些检查工具可以是其他人工智能系统，或者它们可能只是实际的代码，但对我来说，当我听到诸如“人工智能使用了太多的技巧块”或者它们经常“重新发明轮子”之类的问题时，很多都是强化学习（RL）问题。
for instance like which is basically if the reward is just solved the task yeah you know like code reuse doesn't really matter but like and defensibility like matters for RL because otherwise you get like syntax errors and those are bad and they like shoot down your reward. And so like I think there's quite a bit of interesting research to do like with reward shaping with like adversarial training. I think that make these things really interesting. But it's like one of those things where I expect like in the same way like hallucination was like a big problem until like it just seems like it's not right now, like post-thinking models
例如，如果奖励只是解决任务，是的，你知道，代码重用并不重要，但防御性对于强化学习很重要，因为否则你会得到语法错误，这些是糟糕的，它们会降低你的奖励。所以，我认为在奖励塑造和对抗性训练方面有很多有趣的研究要做。我认为这让这些事情变得非常有趣。但这就像我预期的那样，就像幻觉曾经是一个大问题，直到现在看起来不是了，比如思考后的模型
and like web search. I think a lot of these problems people are complaining about it around code reuse will be solved by like AI systems even without a harness. Like they'll just swallow their harness over time. It's just that the harness lets us explore their current capabilities without waiting for like a new model release. Yeah. And similarly, like, I mean, you could like come up with a kernel with like thousands of dollars,
以及网络搜索。我认为人们抱怨的很多关于代码重用的问题，即使没有约束，也会被人工智能系统解决。它们最终会随着时间的推移吞噬掉它们的约束。只是约束让我们能够探索它们当前的能力，而无需等待新模型的发布。是的。同样地，我的意思是，你可以用几千美元想出一个内核，
but eventually, you know, like if you're like a smart human, like presumably you're not going through 30 billion tokens of like Kuda examples before you come up with like a good kernel. Yeah. But you do this much more efficiently. So I think there's also interesting stuff to be done on the search front here. And it's all, like, research I'm quite excited about and stuff, you know, I'm working on. Yeah, yeah.
但最终，你知道，如果你是一个聪明的人，大概你不会在想出一个好的内核之前浏览 300 亿个 CUDA 示例的标记。是的。但你这样做效率更高。所以我认为在搜索方面也有有趣的事情要做。而且这一切，都是我非常兴奋的研究，你知道，我正在做的事情。是的，是的。
I do think there's ways, like, to, to, I don't feel personally like I have fully cracked the search process, like, how to structure the, you know, the orchestration and, like, how to guide a model to actually, like, in particular, the thing that I think remains a challenge is, like, what do you do? How do you prevent a stall? and how do you, you both want to have depth in a search, but you want to have breath too, because maybe you've reached a local maximum, you know, and the thing that I still run into, and I've now heard lots of other people run into is just sort of sometimes you reach this point where you're on the search, this is really just for things where you're trying to really write the speed of light thing, where you, your automated process stalls out eventually. And I think part of it is if you don't shake.
我确实认为有一些方法，可以，我个人并不觉得我已经完全破解了搜索过程，比如，如何构建，你知道，编排，以及，如何引导模型真正地，特别是，我认为仍然是一个挑战的事情是，你该怎么办？你如何防止停滞？以及你如何，你既想在搜索中有深度，但也想有广度，因为也许你已经达到了局部最大值，你知道，我仍然遇到的事情，而且我现在听说很多人也遇到过，只是有时你会达到这一点，你在搜索中，这真的只是针对那些你试图真正写出光速级别的东西，你的自动化过程最终会停滞。我认为部分原因是如果你不调整。
the reward and the metric right, then like it can end up writing like spaghetti code. And like once it's written like 10,000 lines of slop and it's got lots of code that's like dead code in there, then it becomes hard for it to like evolve the code. And, uh, you know, at some point like maybe it makes like if I was a human, at some point I might go and start fresh. And it's like how do you properly guide the model like that it's time to go try a new approach? So, So the analogy I think of is like, it's almost like, it's going to be a weird analogy, so bear with me. It's almost like, let's say you had a light bulb and you're like, it's a lit light bulb and then you're throwing it in like a dark part of a room. To me, this is how I feel like auto research helps me, which is basically I have like an idea and I'd like to explore the limits of that idea, whether it's good.
奖励和指标不对，那么它最终可能会写出像意大利面条一样的代码。一旦它写了 10,000 行垃圾代码，并且里面有很多像死代码一样的代码，那么它就很难进化代码了。而且，你知道，在某种程度上，也许它会，如果我是人类，在某种程度上我可能会重新开始。这就像你如何正确地引导模型，让它知道是时候尝试一种新方法了？所以，我想到的类比是，这几乎就像，这将是一个奇怪的类比，所以请忍受我。这几乎就像，假设你有一个灯泡，你说，这是一个点亮的灯泡，然后你把它扔进房间的一个黑暗角落。对我来说，这就是我觉得自动研究如何帮助我的方式，基本上我有一个想法，我想探索这个想法的极限，无论它是否好。
But in terms of like idea generation, like what's been more helpful for me honestly has been like reading old books, which is just like, you know, I'm sure these are probably a. already in the corpus, they've been scanned or what have you. But it's like one of those things where like, like, you know, despite so many people doing Colonel LAM testing, for instance, I wasn't aware of any prior work that does property-based testing in the way like LAPAC does. So like there seems to be like a basic read the literature aspect here. And yes, you could tell they I read all the literature and do this. Like, yes.
但就想法生成而言，老实说，对我更有帮助的是阅读旧书，这就像，你知道，我相信这些可能已经在语料库中了，它们已经被扫描了，或者诸如此类。但这就像其中一件事，你知道，尽管有很多人在做内核 LAM 测试，例如，我不知道有任何先前的研究以 LAPAC 的方式进行基于属性的测试。所以似乎有一个基本的阅读文献的方面在这里。是的，你可以告诉人工智能阅读所有文献并做到这一点。是的。
But but but but but but but but but but but but but but but I think like it's still quite powerful to have a tool to the limits of how good and ideas. And then, you know, as you sort of get into war shaping, like, it's basically a conversation between you and the AI to figure out, like, what you actually want. And if it's desirable. I guess I may be, I may be, like, to an extreme here, where I, like, almost all of my work is, like, completely unsteered.
但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，我认为拥有一个工具来测试一个想法有多好仍然是非常强大的。然后，你知道，当你进入奖励塑造时，这基本上是你和人工智能之间的对话，以弄清楚你真正想要什么。以及它是否可取。我想我可能，我可能，处于一个极端，我，几乎我所有的工作，都是完全不受引导的。
Like, I don't want to give the model. I don't want to be the one that comes up with the idea. I want the model to be the idea factory. And I have both noticed and fear giving it specific. specific steering or specific ideas or instructions because if I tell it, if I give it an example of like five things, like if I put in a skill an example of five things, it's going to pay a lot of attention to those five things. It's not going to try five things like those things. It's not going to necessarily use this example. It's really going to focus on those five things.
就像，我不想给模型。我不想成为那个想出想法的人。我希望模型成为想法工厂。我既注意到也害怕给它具体的引导或具体的想法或指令，因为如果我告诉它，如果我给它五个东西的例子，比如如果我在技能中放入五个东西的例子，它会非常关注那五个东西。它不会尝试像那些东西一样的五个东西。它不一定会使用这个例子。它真的会专注于那五个东西。
And if I, you know, if I'm truly searching for like a frontier kernel for something, I have a bunch of biases and I don't have. the capacity to generate ideas at the rate it does. And so I feel like it's very interesting to just let it unprompted search on its own. Let it cook. Yeah. So I will say like I do have some data for this. It's a bit out of date now. This is like February-based data. But at the time, I remember when we were working on the NVIDIA problems for NVFP-4, we were releasing solutions per problem, like whenever a problem concludes, we release solution. And they're all NVFP-4 problems. And before our competition, there was almost no NVF4 data on the public internet.
如果我，你知道，如果我真的在为某事寻找前沿内核，我有很多偏见，我没有能力以它那样的速度产生想法。所以我感觉让它在没有提示的情况下自己搜索是非常有趣的。让它自己发挥。是的。所以我得说，我确实有一些关于这个的数据。现在有点过时了。这是基于二月的数据。但在当时，我记得当我们研究 NVFP-4 的 NVIDIA 问题时，我们正在为每个问题发布解决方案，每当一个问题结束时，我们就发布解决方案。它们都是 NVFP-4 问题。在我们的比赛之前，公共互联网上几乎没有 NVFP-4 数据。
But then when Gounhurst released his NVF4, GemV, which is a very high-quality gem-V, in that problem, almost no AI system was in the top 10. No AI system in the top 10. But then as soon as they had Gowner's example, which is, oh, here's a minimal way of how you can use NVFP4 correctly, then all of a sudden everyone reused that trick and figured out how to auto-research it for a gem, for a gem, dual gem, group gem. and then the AIs were doing way, way better, basically, after that. But they needed the, like, if the token is truly rare in some sense, like a new hardware
但后来当 Gounhurst 发布了他的 NVF4, GemV，这是一个非常高质量的 gem-V，在那个问题中，几乎没有人工智能系统进入前 10 名。没有人工智能系统进入前 10 名。但一旦他们有了 Gowner 的例子，即，哦，这是一个关于你如何正确使用 NVFP4 的最小化方法，那么突然间每个人都重用了那个技巧，并弄清楚了如何为 gem, dual gem, group gem 进行自动研究。然后人工智能在之后做得好多了，基本上。但它们需要，如果标记在某种意义上确实很少见，比如一个新的硬件
feature, it hasn't done this work. But you're right. Like, I mean, you mentioned earlier, like, why can't you just plop an agent and then have it port all your code? Well, you know, like, one extreme version of this is just like plop the agent. And I don't know, it figures out like the ISO and it figures out that it should append the cutlass and the string of your kernels. And it should figure out all these things.
特性，它还没有做这项工作。但你是对的。我的意思是，你之前提到过，为什么你不能直接放置一个代理，然后让它移植你所有的代码？嗯，你知道，这的一个极端版本就是直接放置代理。我不知道，它弄清楚了 ISO，它弄清楚了它应该附加到 cutlass 和你的内核字符串中。它应该弄清楚所有这些事情。
but like I think we all know aspirationally that this is where we'd like to get to. It's basically somewhere in between a performance engineer slash reverse engineer slash like it's sort of like these archetypes are becoming like one and the same. And if we could get like AIs to do that, I feel like that's it. Like basically kernel writing would be solved. Yeah. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where
但我认为我们都知道，从愿望上讲，这就是我们想要达到的目标。它基本上介于性能工程师、逆向工程师之间，或者说，这些原型正在变得合二为一。如果我们能让人工智能做到这一点，我觉得这就成了。基本上内核编写问题就解决了。是的。请务必在你的播客应用程序中或在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们在今天剧集中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，在那里
you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed. a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information.
你可以留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢。祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。
And I actually know while I'm taking a little digression, I am baffled on what's going on with my internet right now. Supposedly like my Wi-Fi is down. Technically there's a green light on the Deco, but like I've been trying to like Google stuff while we've been chatting and like the internet doesn't work. And I had a banner at one point. on teams that said like teams is not able to verify your identity but like I don't actually know like somehow I'm getting Wi-Fi but there maybe there's some like authentication thing that's
而且我实际上知道，虽然我稍微离题了，但我对我的互联网现在发生了什么感到困惑。据称我的 Wi-Fi 断了。技术上 Deco 上有一个绿灯，但就像我一直在尝试在聊天时谷歌搜索东西，互联网无法工作。我曾经在 Teams 上有一个横幅，上面写着 Teams 无法验证你的身份，但我实际上不知道，不知何故我正在连接 Wi-Fi，但也许有一些身份验证的事情
like failing which is actually what's causing the Wi-Fi to fail anyways I'm here somehow seeing and hearing you guys so we'll keep going There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
失败了，这实际上是导致 Wi-Fi 失败的原因。无论如何，我在这里不知何故看到了你们并听到了你们的声音，所以我们将继续。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。